llegó el momento de hablar y repasar
toda la prensa internacional con rosa
pérez más de eeuu en revista de prensa
de centroamérica rosa bienvenida ya
estamos a miércoles y abrimos esta
sección de revista de prensa contiene
cuestiones cuesta en una publicación en
el país de rusia impulsa la campaña de
reclutamiento y da un paso hacia una
movilización de guerra rosa buenos días
raúl exactamente no esto nos cuenta este
periodista que dice que a pesar de que a
principios de mayo el kremlin tildó de
tontería la idea de una movilización
general hay ciertos indicios que apuntan
a que efectivamente esta movilización de
los reservistas se estaría pues está
preparando dice el periodista en los
buzones de muchos rusos están llegando
desde hace semanas confusas cartas que
les invitan a acudir a una oficina de
registro militar para aclarar sus datos
de cara a una movilización de las
reservas humanas dice que pues los rusos
que están recibiendo estas cartas no
recuerdan precedentes parecidos también
cabe destacar raúl que si bien este
artículo habla de estas cartas que
estarían recibiendo los rusos no se
muestran en el artículo no hay imágenes
a no pero bueno dice también que según
los testigos con los que ha podido
hablar el periodista que han querido
mantenerse en anonimato
una vez en estas oficinas se toman nota
de quién podría efectivamente ser
enviado a la guerra también se solicitan
exámenes médicos y en ciertos casos pues
digamos se insiste en a los hombres para
que firmen contratos de cara a una
potencial movilización y distintas ong
señalan que estos contratos pues no son
obligatorios no de firmar pero pues que
digamos el ejército estaría contando con
el hecho de que mucha gente no sabe que
no está obligada a firmarlo y hay
digamos otros tres ejemplos que señala
el periodista que vendrían a respaldar
esta tesis de esta pues esa supuesta
preparación de una movilización de los
reservistas por un lado una ong llamada
ágora señaló que en san petersburgo un
centro de estos de reclutamiento exigió
a una empresa que entregara sus
furgonetas para tareas de movilización
por otro lado una la esposa de un
trabajador del metro de moscú aseguró a
la prensa local que supuestamente se
exigió de voz a los todos los
trabajadores hombres del metro de moscú
que se sometieron a exámenes médicos
también han de cara a ser enviados a la
guerra en ucrania y por otro lado
también en páginas de empleo según el
periodista cuesta pues estarían
apareciendo ofertas laborales de cara
pues a personas que estén capacitadas
para gestionar esta movilización pero
tampoco encontramos en el artículo
capturas de pantalla de estas ofertas ni
nada parecido esto hay que dejarlo claro
sin embargo raúl para terminar la
movilización de los reservistas en todo
caso tendría que ser decretada por el
presidente vladimir putin que recordemos
hasta el momento ni siquiera ha
decretado el estado oficial de guerra
para el kremlin para rusia esto continúa
siendo todavía una operación militar
especial récord y continuamos rosa con
una investigación del medio año recogida
también por el mosquito sobre las bajas
de soldados rusos en ucrania en estella
98 de invasión exacto moscú times recoge
esta investigación de este medio rius
ruso inews basado eso sí en letonia bien
la periodista alexia marocco busca ya
parte del principio de que pues el
número de soldados rusos fallecidos en
ucrania varía mucho en función de la
fuente no por un lado la inteligencia
del reino unido- habla de unos 15 mil
soldados rusos no muertos en el combate
en ucrania mientras que la última
actualización de las fuerzas armadas de
kiev del 29 de mayo dice que se
barajaría esta cifra entre los 24.000 y
30.000 soldados muertos entre las filas
del enemigo y por último recordemos que
la última actualización con la que
contamos por parte de moscú es del 25 de
marzo de hace dos meses y que la cifró
en
1.351 pues a las muertes de los soldados
rusos en ucrania bien es muy complicado
esclarecer estas cifras no hay listado
oficial por lo que la periodista dice
sin embargo a veces las regiones o los
distritos donde vivían los soldados que
han muerto anuncian estos fallecimientos
de alguna manera así como las escuelas o
los clubes deportivos donde estudiaban o
entrenaban de este modo llegan a cruzar
no los distintos nombres y verifican al
menos tres mil 43 pues identidades de
soldados rusos que estarían ya
fallecidos pues en el marco de esta
invasión rusa de ucrania y que el 80 por
ciento de estas identidades verificadas
serían de hombres de entre 18 y 35 años
rosas de remojo una viñeta de auto
pública en el medio latinoamericano de
investigación el faro exactamente lo que
hace referencia a la situación en el
salvador porque digamos que se cumplen
tres años de presidencia de nadie bukele
en pleno pues estado de excepción que
fue recordemos decretado el 27 de marzo
y que el 26 de mayo se prorrogó por un
tercer período no precisamente por esto
esta viñeta se titula la nueva
normalidad no este estado de excepción y
pues hace referencia a estas redadas y
detenciones masivas que se están
produciendo en el país y vemos que la
primera detenida es la justicia no
solamente raúl por el lo que comentaba
así lo que nos comentaba aurora también
sino porque pues por el hecho de que
destituyera a decenas de jueces no bucle
sino también porque se consideran por
muchas ongs estas detenciones
arbitrarias no y que se están vulnerando
muchos derechos fundamentales sin
embargo hay que recordar como decías que
el presidente salvadoreño cuenta con un
90 por ciento de aprobación
eso sí queríamos destacar que también
fue este medio el faro este medio de
investigación a tan importante de
nuestra región que reveló que este
estado de excepción no fue decretado
recordemos después de que hubiera un
récord de homicidios el 26 de marzo
supuestamente a manos de las pandillas
lo que fuera una venganza no
precisamente de las maras contra el
gobierno salvadoreño por haber pues
vulnerado por haber roto este digamos
acuerdo no escrito con precisamente las
del país así es rosa un tema que por
supuesto vamos a ampliar esta mañana en
directo américa vamos a saludar entonces
nuestro primer invitado el día